Supernatural's Sam and Dean Winchester, played
by Jared Padalecki and Jensen Ackles, battled
legions of monsters for 15 seasons alongside
countless guest stars. Some left until their
characters returned to life, some left because
their characters were misunderstood, and some
left for other reasons. Find out why they
really said goodbye.
Mark Sheppard played Crowley, the demonic
King of Hell, in seasons 5 through 12, and
he became an integral part of the show. He
secretly aided and openly antagonized the
Winchester brothers, acting as a friend or
foe whenever it was most convenient for his
purposes. But Sheppard felt that his character
deserved a better send-off from the show than
the way his final exit was written, in which
he sacrificed himself on an angel's blade.
In a fan Q&A, he expressed his disappointment,
saying,
"Once they decided they needed to do something
different [with the direction of the show],
they tried to get rid of me without telling
me that they were going to get rid of me.
[...] I'd gone from being the smartest character
on the show to being the dumbest character
on the show in two seasons. They ran out of
what to do."
"No one in the history of torture's been tortured
with torture like the torture you'll be tortured
with…"
Needless to say, Sheppard did not part company
with the show on the best of terms.
DJ Qualls joined Supernatural in season seven
as demon hunter Garth Fitzgerald, who preferred
working alone but was occasionally willing
to team up with the Winchesters. He later
underwent an intense transformation when he
became a werewolf.
Qualls was very appreciative of the fans’
enthusiastic support, and said he had loved
working on Supernatural, but there was simply
no room in his schedule to return to the show.
He told TVGuide,
"I'm so busy right now. [...] I'm on a couple
different shows, and I have two films lined
up after this."
He regretted having let the Supernatural fandom
down, and promised to make time for the show,
eventually returning for guest spots in seasons
14 and 15.
Katie Cassidy was the first actress on the
show to play Ruby, a demon who almost tore
the Winchester brothers' close relationship
apart. Cassidy said she felt that leaving
Supernatural was heartbreaking. Why did she
exit, despite loving her time on the show
so much?
According to series creator Eric Kripke, the
production company could no longer afford
to keep her on the payroll. But Cassidy offered
a slightly different explanation.
She told TVGuide,
"Warner Bros. wasn't exactly sure what they
were going to be doing with my character,
and I had the option to stay or leave. [...] When
Harper's Island came about, I was really into
it, so I asked them to let me go. Luckily,
they did."
When Genevieve Cortese joined the cast of
Supernatural in season four to take over the
role of the demon Ruby, she didn't expect
that it would completely change her life.
But Ruby’s scandalous on-screen relationship
with Sam Winchester blossomed into Genevieve’s
real-life romance with Jared Padalecki, who
admitted that he waited about four months
before asking her on a date. His patience
paid off in a big way: They were married not
long after the fourth season wrapped, and
she became Genevieve Padalecki.
In 2012, Genevieve gave birth to the couple's
first child, a son named Thomas, and then
their children Austin and Odette arrived soon
after in 2013 and 2017. Padalecki has focused
on family since then, largely retiring from
acting, but did return to Supernatural for
a guest spot in the final season.
Jeffrey Dean Morgan was an original cast member
on Supernatural. He played Sam and Dean's
father John Winchester, who became a demon
hunter after his wife -- Sam and Dean’s
mother -- was killed by a demon. Given how
important he was in the brothers’ lives,
having sent them down their path, it’s surprising
he doesn't appear much past season three.
Although the showrunners had wanted to keep
him on and feature him more after season 2,
Morgan’s busy schedule left them with no
choice.
Writer Sera Gamble told Digital Spy,
"We would love to have him back, but he's
really busy. He's turned into a huge star
over here! We got to use his voice for an
episode at the end of last season, so there's
always a chance. We would love to bring back
the character if our schedules ever lined
up, but I don't think anyone should hold their
breath."
Thankfully, Morgan was able to return for
several guest spots as John in later seasons
of the show.
Alona Tal became part of the Supernatural
cast in season two as Jo Harvelle, whose mother
Ellen was a friend of the Winchesters’ dad.
Jo teamed up with them to hunt demons until
her death, and appeared as a ghost in season
seven, then never returned again.
Tal said that she would have embraced the
opportunity to appear on Supernatural again
as Jo, but she worried that the show’s new
leadership didn't seem to fully understand
what she and Samantha Ferris, who had played
her mother, had brought to the table.
She told MEA Worldwide,
"I think what happened was that when Samantha
and I were part of the show, there were different
heads of creative. But the people [running
things] there have changed and I don't think
they know us very well or know our characters."
She also stated that she hoped to appear in
the series’ final season, but it didn't
pan out.
Julian Richings played Death himself, also
known as the Grim Reaper or the Pale Horseman,
on Supernatural. His appearances were rare
but unforgettable, especially considering
Death’s weakness for fattening food — he
just couldn't resist eating a meal at a diner.
Richings made his final appearance as Death
in season 10, and in the following seasons
Lisa Berry took over the role. By the time
his last episode had come around, Richings
had already taken on a new recurring role
as the shadowy Benjamin Kertland on Orphan
Black, and it was the perfect time to step
away. Richings always seems to have a full
schedule, and since then, he's landed roles
on series including 12 Monkeys and Doom Patrol.
Richard Speight Jr. played the archangel Gabriel,
disguised as the trickster Loki. Though always
mischievous, Gabriel eventually sided with
the Winchesters. Gabriel met his end in season
13 — but as it turned out, Speight himself
never really left Supernatural at all.
In addition to acting, Speight left his mark
by directing several episodes of the series,
including some in the final season. He was
behind the camera for "Proverbs 17:3," "Our
Father, Who Aren't in Heaven," and "Galaxy
Brain."
Kurt Fuller appeared on Supernatural as the
villainous angel Zachariah. Fuller embraced
the chance to play an unsaintly bad guy and
ended up really enjoying it — in fact, he
felt a little guilty about it! Admitting to
himself he needed a change, Fuller jumped
at the opportunity to join the situation comedy
Better With You, which he described. as "a
welcome relief" after his time on Supernatural.
He told Staying In,
"Making people laugh rather than making people
bleed is much more fun. And I feel better
about it. This is definitely better for my
soul."
Carrie Anne Fleming appeared on Supernatural
as Karen Singer, wife of supporting character
Bobby Singer. She had been possessed by a
demon and then killed by her husband Bobby,
who didn't understand the paranormal nature
of what had happened to her.
Fleming’s first guest appearance on the
show was marred by personal troubles, as she
struggled with postpartum depression at the
time. Sadly, she was also preparing to leave
her marriage.
Fleming would later joke to fans that "white
clown makeup and no sleep" was all it took
to make her look like a genuine zombie. But
at the time, she was so deeply troubled she
could barely get through a day on set.
She told Times Colonist,
"I was having trouble being happy. [...] I
had trouble memorizing dialogue and communicating."
She did return to Supernatural in season seven,
which was hopefully a better experience.
Fans of Supernatural know Rick Worthy as the
Alpha Vampire, the very first member of the
vampire species. But when Worthy first auditioned,
he had wanted to play a much more prominent
and longer-term role: Crowley!
He told Digital Spy,
"I really wanted to be on the show, and I
had auditioned probably five or six times
before. [...] I auditioned for the role of
Crowley, which I thought was a great role,
and was devastated, just devastated [when
I didn't get it]."
Unfortunately, because Worthy wasn't chosen
for a major role, he couldn't stay on Supernatural
as long as he’d really wanted. He went on
to other roles including the strict Dean Fogg
on The Magicians.
"Now, when we "freaks" die... where do we
go? Not heaven, not hell. So?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don’t miss
a single one.